those of the station staff, underwriters or volunteers.
Time is made available for all sorts of viewpoints, and thank you so much for choosing to listen
to us in a crowded media landscape.
And support for KMUD comes from the Redwood Coast Energy Authority, who provides services
and support to the community to build energy resilience, reduce energy consumption and
expand the use of climate-friendly electric vehicles.
Visit redwoodenergy.org for complete details or call 707-269-1700 for more information.
It's time for Ask Your Herb Doctor.
Thank you.
Well, once again,
it's Ask Your Herb Doctor, KMUD Garberville 91.1 FM.
Welcome back.
So every month we have a guest speaker, and that guest speaker is the faithful, ever-reliable,
factual, informative Dr. Raymond Peat.
And again, this month is no exception, Dr. Peat is going to be joining us to discuss
the continuing subject of cancer with reference to autoimmunity and estrogen.
For those people who wish to call in, we invite you to call in, it's a live show.
We encourage the questions related to the subject, but obviously recognize there are
instances where people are following protocols and they have questions related to that protocol.
Or indeed any other subject, as Dr. Peat say, a wealth of information.
And outside of his area of expertise, he often has an answer for many different questions.
So this month, like I said, it's a continuation of a broader discussion on cancer.
The alternative approach is the treatment of cancer, some new research that I found
here from some 19, sorry, 2020 papers and 2019 papers that have been written on immunotherapy
and estrogen and autoimmunity.
So from 7.30 until the end of the show at 8 o'clock, you're invited to call in.
The number is 707-K-M-U-D-RAD or 986-3911, 923, sorry, 923-3911, so it's area code 707-923-3911.
So I think without further ado, let's make sure we've got Dr. Peat on the air and that
we can get his explanations as we go through this next 40, 50 minutes.
Okay.
Dr. Peat?
Yes, I'm here.
Thanks so much for joining us.
So for those people, as always, I start the shows off just in case.
For those people who perhaps might not have read anything that you've written or heard
you speak or know anything about you, perhaps it's always possible to meet people coming
all the time into the alternative scene.
Would you just explain your academic and professional background before we get into the show?
Okay, when I graduated from college, that was in the humanities.
I was an English major for a while and then an art and psychology and philosophy major
for a while and worked for several years just in the humanities, but I was specializing
in linguistics and wanted to understand how language works in the brain.
So I decided to study biology to better understand the brain so I could understand language as
a basis for understanding the culture and humanities and so on.
But when I got to graduate school at University of Oregon 1968, I learned that the brain scientists
were the most dogmatic, well the geneticists were more dogmatic, the brain science people
were high status and very dogmatic, so I looked around looking for people oriented towards
science rather than dogmatism and found that reproductive physiology people were actually
doing research and not throwing away evidence that contradicted them, their basic ideas.
So I specialized in the physiology of oxidative metabolism as it changes in the reproductive
system with aging and that happened to provide a good perspective on how to understand the
brain and its energy and so it was useful for my original project and so then I wrote
up Mind and Tissue, a little book about the history of people understanding brain metabolism
in relation to psychology and then for 10 or 20 years it was specializing in the interactions
of hormones and nutrition counseling people and the effects of living and eating on your
hormonal system and aging.
It's something I picked up on there, you said that when you decided to follow up your undergraduate
stuff you said that the reproductive physiology people were far less likely to throw away
good information related to the research and therefore a little bit more careful in sticking
to scientific principles and not burying it and I just want to ask you the question before
we get into the subject matter, is this because the estrogen industry hadn't really gotten
so much traction at this point, by this point it was still in the early days of its push
towards and I guess it links tonight's show because we're talking about estrogen and auto
immunity but did you say that those reproductive physiology people or the people in those departments
weren't quite so inclined to throw this stuff away or mire it?
My brain neurobiology professor in class described doing some research and he said that and then
you throw away the bad data and in the lab I would point out an instrument reading to
him that was impossible by his ideas and that just turned off his brain in a flash and he
turned away and I'm sure his memory was that he never saw that happen.
Okay, let's just hold that thought there for a second Dr. Peatand.
I have an underwriter I forgot to read and we love our underwriters because they keep
us going. I'm 11 minutes late. The Southern Humboldt Chamber of Commerce is excited to
present their Small Town Christmas, Saturday, December 18th. Festivities will begin about
2.30 and end with the Soroptimist lighted truck parade about 6pm. Come to downtown Garberville
and enjoy a carriage ride, face painting SFHS boosters at South Fork High School boosters
will offer pulled pork and Miranda 4-H club will have sweet treats. Special deals at merchants
throughout town and don't forget to come say hi to Santa and share with him your holiday
wishes. Ho ho ho. Okay, so Dr. Peatgetting back to the subject of tonight's Estrogen Autoimmunity
article that was pulled from but it was one of those 2021 articles from PubMed. So PubMed,
okay, as a university paper but I didn't actually have this one down. So they just said that
why women are more susceptible to autoimmune disease is not completely clear but new data
suggests that the hormone estrogen may play an important role. A new study now shows that
estrogen activates the expression of AID which is activation induced deaminase which is a
protein that drives antibody diversification by deaminating cytosine in DNA to uracil.
If estrogen increases the level of AID increased mutations could transform benign antibodies
into anti-self pariahs and AID might also contribute to cancer particularly in breast
tissue which is highly responsive to estrogen by introducing mutations and strand breaks
into the genome. So I just wanted to read that out because the conversation I had earlier
with Dr. Peatabout tonight's show, he said that he was looking more and doing more research
into autoimmunity and how estrogen unfavourably influences the immune system to basically
become a self-destructive mechanism or by knocking out things like nuclear factor kappa
beta. That article you cited is an extremely important landmark in not just autoimmunity
but one of the very earliest estrogen cancer researchers, Leonel Strong, showed that estrogen
destabilizes the whole genome, promotes a tendency to develop an uneven number of chromosomes
by losing or gaining an extra chromosome or piece of chromosome. So it's a genetic destabilizer
and that's exactly what this article you cite. It focuses on one single enzyme which
is when it functions it helps to produce the essentially infinite variety of antibodies
that we can make by creating extreme rate of mutation locally. But that same destabilizing
process works on many levels all the way to the shape and function of the basic cell not
just that one mutation promoting the enzyme. When you look at these landmarks it's important
to keep in mind that in between the big landmarks like that article on the AID mutagenic enzyme,
in between these landmarks you have an almost continuous seamless bunch of other changes
that estrogen is acting on and producing that all tend in the same direction. The reductionist
mechanistic approach just can't look at the fact but wherever you look probably thousands
of different places are cooperating with that destabilizing effect on that one enzyme but
increasing the water content of the cell for example helps to destabilize the whole system
and hardening collagen, lowering oxygen tension, increasing nitric oxide production, histamine
production. Everywhere you look it would take about an hour just to identify the main pro-inflammatory
organisms that have been identified but the interesting thing is it's holistic almost
seamlessly interacting one factor supporting another factor.
Well I'm very pleased that you said that. I was so happy to find the article. I couldn't
hardly believe what I was reading because so often it's been for the last 15 years
well not quite that long with you obviously we met you in 2007 but since I've been looking
at articles to do shows and to come up with information and to discuss things and bring
to the greater awareness people's understanding of how they're being duped as it were by the
system and we'll talk a little bit later on towards the end of the show about the authoritarianism
which you've often mentioned in science and in the university systems. How people are
being duped by the status quo and what they're told to accept or not but I couldn't hardly
believe the article when I read it because along with that and there was another one
a 2019 publication that one was a 2021 publication I was like wow they're actually saying this
they're actually saying it the way it is this is what you've been saying for a long long
time and I know we'll come back to that quip that you've mentioned years and years and years
ago you know a lie gets around the world faster than truth can get tired but shoelaces but
I was so heartened to see this article and read about it because researchers and scientists
were actually disclosing this now and because it's been buried and hidden for so long because
the estrogen industry is so powerful and that's why I mentioned when you first started talking
about your bio you know the people in reproductive physiology perhaps weren't so keen to throw
stuff away because they weren't as brainwashed perhaps probably because the estrogen industry
hadn't got as much traction as it has now both in Congress as well as in pharmaceutical
you know frameworks that there's so much money behind it now that it's very easy to just
blind people to the truth and keep perpetuating the lie in an authoritarian fashion which
the medical system emphasizes and epitomizes completely I've often wondered how my thesis
advisor Arnold Soderwald how he came to be so open to the facts and resistance to the
industry position and I think it was partly that he was born and educated before the power
of the industry took over and so he was aware of the research that was done in the 1930s
absolutely contradicting everything that since 1944 the estrogen industry has foisted under
the public.
Yeah okay we'll get into the meat and potatoes as it were of what you've recently been researching
as a continuation of a thread you've held for a long time along with the polyunsaturates
being so damaging for the system both genetically and energetically so far as autoimmunity and
estrogen is concerned I pulled out quite a few little snippets from either PubMed or
other internet source documents that are researched and validated by references to the articles
by which they're claiming that what they're saying is the way it is so the autoimmunity
feature or the autoimmunity predisposing activity of estrogen and how it's so negative not just
because it's cancer forming but in terms of its destabilizing things as you mentioned
like water logging the cell and decreasing energy availability and causing chaos in the
cell generally how this can result in chromosomal changes but autoimmunity per se and how do
you see estrogen driving that in terms of what you're currently seeing and building
on?
The pro-inflammatory part of inflammation and immunity that is activated by estrogen
such as histamine, nitric oxide and serotonin it's an essential part of getting things started
but the next step is to turn off the excitatory process that got things started and focus
on maturing the cells once they got shaken up by a little inflammation then you have
to give form to it and estrogen releasing histamine for example activates many other
pro-inflammatory things and activates cells that get cell division going and increases
the production of antibodies the B cells are activated by estrogen and the whole thymus
gland shrinks very quickly in the presence of either estrogen or glucocorticoids and
if you knock out the thymus T cells that restrain the antibody production of things like this
enzyme you just cited AID those become more and more dominant the B cells being activated
in many ways by estrogen including knocking out the restraint from the T cells that creates
varied sort of random irrational activity of the antibodies being produced by this overactivity
of the B cells and in that relatively random activity that's where some of the antibodies
cause damage rather than contributing to cleaning up the infection process.
So what goes wrong Dr. Peat if the estrogen is an important stimulator of inflammation
for healing purposes at what point does it go wrong or why does it go wrong that it then
becomes a chronic inflammatory stimulator?
Yeah it's exactly the same thing that happens in pregnancy estrogen and histamine create
a little focus of activity in the uterus and inflammation that the conceptus takes advantage
of and gets into the uterus but then if that process of local inflammation histamine and
estrogen kept dominating it would interfere with the oxygen and glucose supply.
Yeah you've got to stop the excitation and the inflammation for the pregnancy to really
start by delivering glucose and oxygen to the tissue.
It's progesterone rising one of the natural functions of estrogen is to evoke the progesterone
receptor making the cells open to being turned off by progesterone.
So it's sort of an automatic process the estrogen should excite and inflame the tissue but immediately
turn the tissue towards looking for relief from progesterone by increasing the progesterone
receptor and if you can produce progesterone partly acting through the progesterone receptor
partly outside that way of influencing, one of the first effects of progesterone is to
knock out the estrogen roughly ten different ways progesterone knocks out those pro-inflammatory
effects of estrogen turning off the production of estrogen knocking out the estrogen receptor
so the tissue is less sensitive to estrogen and changing the metabolism and so on and
exactly what happens to make pregnancy possible is what happens every time you have a little
injury that evokes the estrogen activated start of the healing or immune process that should
increase the cells ability to receive and be saved or matured by progesterone produced
elsewhere in the organism.
So for women that have autoimmune conditions is that something you would recommend they
use as progesterone to help combat the inflammatory overactive immune stimulating effects of the
estrogen?
People are now recognizing the role of progesterone along with DHEA and thyroid but over the last
fifty years or so I have seen several women with seriously debilitating effects of lupus
SLE lupus erythematosus and just by taking thyroid and progesterone all of their symptoms
over several weeks faded away.
Because the thyroid is combating the estrogen helping improve the liver's ability to excrete
it and detoxify it and increasing the oxygen to the cell to get it to work better so it
can not be over manufacturing inflammatory mediators and making more progesterone and
helping the progesterone production to counterbalance the high estrogen and what role do you think
like plastics in our environment play stimulating estrogens I mean is this something that we're
now going to be permanently scarred with, women and men, children?
I'm glad you mentioned that because that's actually part of another question I had for
later on but carry on.
The water, birth control pills getting into the sewage much of it ends up in the water
of rivers and recycles and there are natural sources of estrogens but just the tremendous
flow of estrogen down the sewers is a tremendous polluting source but the plastics, the agents
used to make stiff plastics more flexible are the effective estrogen in very small amounts
and all of the water supply of the world is contaminated with those.
They're saying that the levels of cancer now that they're putting down and I'm glad you
said that.
I'll back up Sarah to just say that one of the questions I was going to pose to you is
around bisphenoA and the catastrophe that we're seeing worldwide with environmental
contaminants from the plastics industry is fuelling the cancer rates worldwide because
it's directly implicated in the estrogenisation of the organism, male or female, as well as
fish and everything else that's swimming about in the water.
So you're listening to ask your Dr. K.M.U.D. Garberville 91.1 FM, Dr. Raymond Peat PhD is
with us and we are discussing the subject of auto-immunity, cancer and estrogen.
Right about now, 7.30 to 8 o'clock, you're invited to call in the questions either directly
pose to Dr. Peat on the subject or any other health questions that you have.
The number here is 707-923-3911 and so we'll be taking calls from now until 8 o'clock.
Well that's not quite getting to the plastics yet but I think just on the subject of auto-immunity
and how the immune system basically targets itself when it's under the effects of estrogen
and how that can fuel cancer through chromosomal changes and damage that puts the body's immune
surveillance outside of the range of doing what it should do but turns it against itself.
I looked at, because they've always said, well not always said but fairly recently in
the last 15, 20 years they've been saying that viruses, oncogenetic viruses have been
discovered and that they posited then 20, 30 years ago perhaps that these viruses may
well be implicated in spontaneous cancer arising and I remember things like walk viruses being
implicated in the production of cancers but Epstein-Bardvina virus is also another one
of those.
I saw in some recent research related to autoimmune disease such as Hashimoto's thyroiditis and
Graves disease rheumatoid and then you mentioned Lupus and Shergens syndrome so the viral interference
as it were towards promoting destabilization and autoimmune thyroid disease from viral
inclusions as an autoimmunity.
Do you go along with that kind of theory?
The same inflammation that leads to the direct actions of estrogen on the T and B cells and
on their ability to make the safe type of antibodies, whatever the inflammation is affecting all
of the cells of your body, shifting them a little bit to the unstable tendency to lack
enough oxygen and take up more water than is desirable.
I think we have a caller on the air, our first one for this evening so let's hold you right
there Dr. Peatand take this first caller, caller where are you from and what's your question?
I'm from square away and this is Joe and I was wondering if there's a correlation between
the plastics makers and the pharmaceutical industry.
The people who are making the plastic and the people who are holding the patents to
the chemical therapy, I don't doubt that for a minute but Dr. Peatin terms of petrochemical
industries and pharmaceutical companies, what do you think about that collusion perhaps?
But it's known fact that the round up company also holds the patents to the medicine that
cures the same illness or pretends to cure the symptoms of the illness that the dandelion
root would cure.
I totally agree.
Dr. P, what do you have to say?
The other question I have, when will they be held accountable for destroying this earth?
Yeah, when will they be held accountable for a lot of things, hopefully that's hope.
We all hope for that so let's not give up hope.
But Dr. P, what do you think about petrochemical and pharmaceutical collusion?
Oh, those are the most powerful industry next to the military, arms industry and they have
had control of the government regulatory agencies for well over a hundred years and it's a less
powerful industry, the asbestos industry compared to pharmaceuticals and petrochemicals.
Asbestos wasn't such a huge powerful industry but it took about a hundred years to reduce
the public's exposure to carcinogenic levels of asbestos.
So the government is working against the public on matters of pollution.
And also Dr. P, haven't you told us that estrogen is manufactured from petrochemical products?
The original ones were a diethylstilbestrol, it was so cheap, it was a perfect drug, cost
nothing to manufacture but it had very powerful estrogen-like effects that led it.
It was continuing to be used to treat prostate cancer right at the very end of the 20th century,
they were still using it.
And that's what you believe causes prostate cancer, right, is the estrogen?
And that treatment was based on zero evidence, it was a total matter of opinion contrary
to all of the research in animals but it affected many millions of men for about 55 years.
That sounds like the true mark of the authoritarian.
True.
Okay, so you're listening to Ask Europe, Dr. K. M. E. D. Garberful, 91.1 FM, Dr. Raymond
P, our special guest here to answer questions either about the subject of tonight's autoimmunity
cancer and estrogen or any other health related questions you have that you feel Dr. Peathas
the answer for and he has the answers.
So the number here is 707 923 3911.
I want to make a little departure from autoimmunity per autoimmunity's sake but just ask you and
I've got a little kind of paragraph of some work I saw of that.
I think, I don't know if you'll go along with it but let me just see if you will.
What do you think about dienylmethane because I have an article about DIM for anti-estrogenic
purposes?
There were studies in the patient which had a pro-estrogenic effect so I've been a little
sceptical of it but to the extent that you can show for example in humans that it is
protective and it's a pretty safe material or just eat your cabbage and broccoli.
Kale, I like kale.
Alright, and then I saw from a botanical perspective, it interests me, I call it right away because
I remember working in the botanic gardens in Cambridge, this plant is climbing cucurbitase
plant in the cucumber family called momordica sharantia, bitter melon, they're saying that
it has strong estrogen modulating properties and that in rats bitter melon reduced estrogen
levels notably and another study found four specific constituents from bitter melon possess
significant antagonism of estradiol and estrogen receptors.
So I wonder if that point caught my attention for any other reasons other than that but
I thought it was quite pertinent, these bright orange kind of gourds, they're not gourd
shaped but they're kind of like swollen cucumbers with lots of spines on them.
So getting back to autoimmunity and other substances that affect estrogen and decrease
estrogen's ability to wreak havoc on the chromosome and to reduce T helper cells and the other
parts of the immune system so that it can evade detection and/or be arrested much sooner
than it is in most people.
There are two factors that powerfully go with the inflammation and destabilizing effect
of estrogen adding to the tendency to develop autoimmunity.
One is endotoxin and if you're overloaded with estrogen your blood vessels tend to be
leaky and that in itself increases the risk of exposure to endotoxin which intensifies
that leakiness and affects all of your cells tending to make them leaky or overloaded with
water and having the signs of inflammation.
The other main factor is the polyunsaturated fatty acids and the prostaglandins that they
are converted to both pre-polyunsaturated fatty acids.
They have a direct effect activating estrogen for example knocking out the estrogen binding
protein so that the estrogen is freed to be more active and effective and increasing the
ability of cells to take up the polyunsaturated fats and then under the influence of estrogen
the excitatory prostaglandins are activated and they in a healthy situation the prostaglandins
are blocked by progesterone in multiple ways.
Stopping the synthesis and accelerating the degrading metabolism of the prostaglandins
with a balance once you shift over to the estrogen influence you're at increased risk
from the polyunsaturated fats and the endotoxin coming from your intestine.
Alright good I'm glad you mentioned that endotoxin and leaky gut because there was another direct
article that associated leaky gut with being the initial insult that allowed these fragments
to pass across into the bloodstream and set up auto-immunity because they are recognized
as foreign and some of these substances they mentioned things like glidin from gluten and
that protein I didn't actually have the time to look at it I looked at the structure of
triiodothyronine and thyroxine someone was saying I can't quote the person's name but
I've got a small paragraph from their article they said that the glidin molecule was very
similar to T3 and T4 structure and how when glidin got across a leaky gut and the permeability
allowed that kind of thing to happen that within the bloodstream our own immune system
unfortunately would recognize that glidin molecule was being so similar to thyroid that
it would actually cause an autoimmune thyroiditis as a consequence do you know anything about
glidin structure? Oh yeah for a long time the cudiac disease has been increasing right along
with the exposure to estrogen it has gone from mostly a childhood disease to mostly
an adult women and there are several things that overlap antigenically with the tissues
under the influence of estrogen and gluten and in particular can I hold you there I don't
need a button Dr Peat we've got two callers on the air so let's take these two callers
first and then we'll carry on yes because we definitely I want to hear what he has to
say about the interaction of gluten and estrogen if we have time yeah let's go gluten so I'll
make a note of that but Dr Peat let's take this first caller out of two caller you're
on the air where you're from what's your question? Hi actually I'm in Garberville right now you
guys started touching on this so maybe it's a perfect time to ask but I was going to ask
I don't want to limit you to three foods but what are like three foods or three categories
of foods one can avoid that are that you would say are highly carcinogenic and as far as the
worst foods for you to put in your body how would you say that would compare I don't know
you can't compare it to say smoking cigarettes thank you so carcinogenic foods
the what food what would you say would be the top three carcinogenic foods
oh uh polyunsaturated fat yeah any vegetable seed oil liquid seed oil that is polyunsaturated
olive oil is 90 percent mono unsaturated 10 percent polyunsaturated otherwise all the other
seed oils are polyunsaturated. So Dr Peat Poufer the first one how about number two? I would put
the pro-inflammatory amino acid tryptophane I would say was a number two methionine cysteine
and tryptophane and what are some foods? Turkey. High quality proteins in excess things like lots
and lots of turkey well that's so that's basically not more than four ounces of meat per day
is what you have generally recommended for someone trying to avoid carcinogenic excess of
protein yeah definitely you don't want to eat a pound or a pound and a half of meat per day
so Poufer pro-inflammatory amino acids particularly tryptophane and what else do
you think number three contender for cancerous foods? I'm not sure anything that contains a
very great excess of iron I think should have a high spot. And how does that relate to smoking
a pack a day of cigarettes? How does it relate to what? Yeah so how is say having a diet rich in
Poufas compared in cancer risk to smoking a pack a day of cigarettes, American cigarettes?
Oh the Poufas are probably the biggest carcinogenic part of the American diet.
Okay that was the first caller thanks for your question caller so let's move on to the second
caller. Caller you're on the air and where you're from what's your question? Yes good evening I'm
calling from Garberville as well I was curious you answered my first question which was the
I eat a lot of olive oil which is unfiltered which is fabulous stuff so you've answered that
question already the mono and so the second question was in relationship to our other caller
who asked what the most carcinogenic foods were does whole wheat flour fall under that and how
about what is the is the constituents of chicken a healthy thing to eat and I'll take my answer up
here thank you very much gentlemen. Whole wheat flour? The reason flour and grains
were polished white rice for example and white flour is that the whole grains get rancid
and toxic fairly quickly in storage and so if you're going to eat the whole wheat flour soon
after it's ground it's probably not so bad but still once it gets in your blood those excess
polyunsaturated fats are starting to react with iron in your blood to produce
lipid peroxides and pre-radical toxins. The polished rice has very little nutritional value
but it has at least a way to see worse effects of storage toxins. The rancidity it's not going to
go rancid white rice. Yeah very very little rancidity. So it prevents starvation because it
doesn't have any other nutrients besides the carbohydrate. I actually I found myself sitting
by an Asian American professor of nutrition and I asked him you know hippies eat brown rice obviously
that's best why isn't that done in Asia and he said there was a storage issue because
with white rice there's not enough nutrition that a weevil can't reproduce but if they're eating
whole grain meals or grains then they're able to reproduce and you get an infestation instead of
just losing a few grains. Well there's another reason. Yeah because it was everybody there ate
tons of vegetables and then in some high quality meat and so it wasn't an issue of fiber and
vitamins it was a storeable transportable food for armies and bureaucrats. And the caller asked
about chicken your specific view on chicken too? On a typical industrial diet chicken is full of
very unstable polyunsaturated fats and I think it in excess is pretty carcinogenic. But if you
had access to good fresh locally raised chicken from a great diet no more than four ounces a day
is okay? Yeah I think so the same with pork industrial pork has over 30 percent PUFAs in the
fat and if people are careful what they feed their pigs the fat goes down almost like beef four
percent of PUFAs of the fat. If you're not feeding them corn and all those PUFAs rich grains then the
fat of the chicken and the fat of the pork or the pig will be less full of those toxic polyunsaturated
or PUFAs oils we call them PUFAs. Yeah like the traditional pig diet of hopefully in old vegetables.
Okay you're listening to Ask Europe. Dr. Jamie D. Garber full 91.1 FM. From now until the close
of the show probably at five to the hour you're invited to call in the question 707 923 3911.
Dr. Peatbefore you lose the train of thought not that you do lose too much if anything much
gluten and estrogen so I wanted to make sure that we got that connection. Yeah there's a
enzyme transglutaminase is in common between gluten and for example the lining of the
intestine acted upon by estrogen and so if we have antibodies to foreign protein gluten
they will act against our own tissues as far as they're under the influence of estrogen
which induces the transglutaminase and the transglutaminase aspect of estrogen
it's the cross-linking enzyme that hardens collagen and under the influence of estrogen
producing transglutaminase collagen itself becomes hardened and carcinogenic.
Rather than flexible. Interesting we have another caller on the air so let's let's go there first.
He was able to do it in five words opinion on eating flax I'm sorry hemp seed and pumpkin seed.
Hemp seed versus pumpkin seed. Or either both.
They are not necessarily the worst for the proof of it I wouldn't say it's something you should
do regularly because of the breakdown products they're probably fairly rancid by the time you
ingest them anyway. Okay we've got one more caller on the air and I think we're going to leave this
next caller coming to be the last one just so that the engineer can clear up for eight o'clock and
I'm going to carry on talking with you Dr Peat. So let's take this next caller away from what's
your question? I'm just from Redway and I my question is you know I'm a construction worker
so I work in that with um you know the typical construction materials be they um you know uh
laminated glues, butyls, ABS glues, I cut APS glue off the pipe all the time and those I would assume
are excluding the same kind of the bioestrogens that you're referring to um I and then you know
and then there's also insulation and those I would really love to hear a program if you don't mind me
hijacking it for a second to to talk about the things that that that uh you know that uh the
general public are exposed to on it but I do I'm you know I would love to hear about ABS and
PVC polyvinyl chloride and and how those um chemicals um react and and I'm afraid I didn't
listen to your show before this but I would really love to know because I do work with them often.
Yeah well Dr. Peatlet's thank you for your question Corey let's give it over to Dr. Peatfirst and then
just remind you that on our website we do run oh 85 percent of the shows that we've done I still
have a lot to put up from 2021. 20 and 21 unfortunately there's some of the hottest
stuff we've done actually on Covid but Dr. Peatthe building materials I mean not just in California
with their supposed safe regulations and we'll get into that at some other point but um the glues
and you know the PVCs and all of their sealants and solvents and Christie's hot glue hate the smell
of that stuff even the safety law system as far as it's existing it's really part of of a
superstructure that enforces the use of the dangerous materials that they have laws to
supposedly protect you against them but the basic system is designed to direct production towards
these cheapest and most dangerous chemicals the in the long run 10 years or more I think the problem
would be solved very economically instead of continuing the deforestation to make lumber
and plywood and and so on and then support fire departments to put out houses that are
burning down living in Mexico I was interested that there are practically no fire departments
because that's all mud and cement and mud and cement are very cheap building materials
they pollute very little you you wind up some some rocks natural and can make your house
any shape you want and it's chemically inert once it gets in place yeah you can burn seashells and
make your own lime slate lime it's just uh okay so that's so what are some dietary strategies
if you've been working all day with these horrible chemicals what should you eat and what should you
do to get that stuff out of your body that's why I was just going to ask Dr Peat in the last couple
minutes of this show let's discuss some ways to help protect ourselves against the carcinogenic
effects of estrogen and I know you've gone on about raw grated carrot and how effective they
aren't helping to decrease the endotoxin that we were talking about earlier but also that they
can actually absorb estrogen from the bowel yeah any good fiber that isn't too poisonous our carrots
have their own poisons but the fiber keeps us from absorbing when when it's raw carrot
and moderately shredded we absorb very little of these irritating or toxic chemicals but
other fibers you might find are more agreeable anything from well-cooked mushrooms or bamboo
foods even to a well-cooked bran oat bran for example has a fiber effect of getting the intestine
out of your intestine so it doesn't recycle and poison your liver
and so keeping the intestine as clean as possible means also keeping a rapid transit time
and avoiding irritating foods that could cause inflammation and constipation
and part of the effect it is to watch that your thyroid isn't suppressed because that will slow
the elimination of estrogen so keeping your metabolic rate up keeping a temperature around
98.6 during the peak of the daytime that will tend to give you a quick peristalsis and
get things through your intestine before they have a chance to irritate and produce endotoxin and
recycle estrogen and the other two supplements that are very helpful with keeping estrogen at bay
or you know in our food of calcium is definitely one of them that helps to keep estrogen levels low
and vitamin d those are two other supplements that you can take or you know hopefully you're
getting your calcium from dairy and green leafy vegetables and because they keep your metabolic
rate higher the way thyroid does the calcium especially from low-fat milk supported by vitamin
d both are very good for weight loss and then lastly one last thing is progesterone is a direct combat
molecule to estrogen okay let's hold it there folks thank you so much for your time dr p i'll
just give out your information here okay okay for those of you who've listened to the show
dr raymond p are raypeat.com plenty of articles to read lots of science backing it
our website western botanical medicine.com we've got probably 12 years 13 14 years of archive shows
i've got all of the shows from 20 and 21 to go up unfortunately haven't done it been very busy but
there are lots of covid shows there to show how ridiculous this entire fast is i wanted just to
finish up the show um we're going to discuss a little bit about authoritarianism and i just
this afternoon when i was getting the stuff together for the show during the course of the
afternoon here um came up with what i want to read out now and it's just like a bit of a eulogy for
you those listening out there and for people for future posterity but basically i called it
authoritarianism and the age of acceptance have it all and have nothing we're evolving as a species
and with our evolution comes the concept of deranged acceptance nature is not accepting but
rather through evolutionary pressure it selects a fittest and is quite barbaric it takes no prisoners
and is quite merciless rules exist and nature obeys them set from the foundation of the world
which we recently have also learned to meddle with and derange like viruses and gain of function
research and the origins of covid the opposite perhaps of the all-encompassing embrace of
everything is allowable are the immutable laws set in place which we are constrained to like time
gravity and death authoritarianism like cultural marxism is at odds with our founding father's
constitution of life liberty and the pursuit of happiness which is a god ordained decree
immutable and self-evident echoing martin luther's famous speech from the emancipation
proclamation like gain of function research and authoritarianism these are set at odds with their
counterpart and are to be resisted with your life evolution demands that fitness be preserved and
aimed at physically and spiritually and so with increasing authoritarianism and draconian
legislation aimed at making us happier to coexist with everything except everything have no boundaries
and have no morals i'll leave you with this have at it or resist and live 2022 will soon be here
but we will move on and for those who have ears let them hear what the spirit says
merry christmas and a happy new year to you all my name is andrew murray my
name is sarah johannison murray thanks for tuning in tonight good night good night
do
well that's an adventure